Imagine a bubble.
It's like walking up the mountain.
It's a cliff on one side,
you know,
you walk higher and higher and maybe it was a crowd of people and then the whole
crowd is st g's.
You know,
it looks like this upwards road goes on forever.
Aren't we doing much better than those fools who stayed on the flat ground?
And the answer to that is absolutely until you take one step over the cliff,
the problem is you're in a fog.
You don't know where the cliffs is,
you don't even know if there is a cliff to probably is a cliff because there's
been a cliff before,
but you know lots of people.
And the media of course was focusing on those people because it was a time of
optimism said,
oh well the rules are different this time we're in a state of permanent economic
expansion.
The Internet has transformed everything.
We're in a new electronic age,
maybe,
maybe
didn't work out that way.
And then everyone says,
well,
we were fools to think that this couldn't happen.
Well,
the problem,
it's going to happen.
The problem is you can't tell when.
That's the problem with life.
It's going to happen and you can't tell him when.